the first scenes have just arrived and
guess what it's trending like crazy we
took a close look at it and they are
borrowing heavily from the original we
have dedicated our whole lives to
studying the paranormal now their
sightings all over the city Rogers is
gonna be dreamy and the boss the
trailers well on its way to getting over
a million views in its first 24 hours
but here's how the reboot pays its
respects to the first movie I remember
the library scene there's a class for
oppression that's okay she seems
peaceful that's step one everywhere by
the way in every crack very hard to wash
off our other favorite throwbacks first
off Slimers back and of course the ecto
mobile gets a revamp didn't disclose
that the vehicle was gonna be a hearse
it's a Cadillac the proton packs are
very 2016 the blasters too and the
Ghostbusters office is even in the same
building as the original added bonus for
the ladies Chris Hemsworth makes an
appearance it's just amazing and it's
it's that's gonna be pretty awesome it
was one of the best times ever it was so
so fun someone is creating a device that
amplifies paranormal activity they might
be the only ones who can stop it the
movie isn't out until July but don't
count on any new hints from Kate
McKinnon I've heard that it's great so
I'll just go with that I cannot wait for
this movie and by the way the day that I
was on the set I lived out my pills
Buster fantasy I got all involved with
the slime it's a story for another day